the devil is real
may God have mercy on us all
first of all I do have to talk with this
film it is scary it's going it is
definitely going there I think Andre has
described it as aliens on a boat
um except for the you know happens to be
like the aliens that it's Dracula but
exactly talk about you sort of joining
in it was that sort of the appeal to It
Horror in general or was it maybe what
you saw in the character oh it was a
little bit of both uh to be honest um
and a lot of Andre's Vision
um first of all when I read the script
and I know it's been around for a long
time I saw this uh incredible character
in Clemens an opportunity that I thought
was important for us to just go after
you know you don't have to hit the nail
over the head with it but he's a black
man a black Cambridge educated doctor at
the turn of the century I think that was
important because these men existed and
so part of it was also the research and
conversations with Andre and our
producers who also wanted to make space
for that and I thought that was great
and important
um especially in the horror genre
because
we're not always uh centered in that way
and it was great to watch
this uh this this man who I think is an
outsider who I think is he represents
the other
um and Dracula represents the other also
the woman the one woman on board played
by Ashling Anna she represents the other
and so there's this Dynamic there that I
thought was just incredible and then
also it's it's it's I'm a horror nerd
I'm a horror geek I never pictured
myself actually like doing it and and
this being my first sort of real sort of
leading in this way
um uh because I've been a part of some
really cool big franchises but to be a
part of bringing Dracula back is is
awesome and also with my first film
seeing my first time some being
introduced to a vampire was Blacula in
the 1970s wow William Marshall and that
black exploitation error so I just think
it's cool to now I mean I wasn't I
didn't see it in the 1970s I saw them
you know when I was when I was alive you
know uh but the VHS you know rocked into
the tank prop
um
you know but it's one of those things
that for me was uh just incredibly
special and it's just a great
opportunity I'm what's so interesting
about it too is the fact that it is a
Dracula movie but you don't even know
that's the movie that you're really in
until about halfway through it's like it
really does take a while to sort of
uncover that but one of the things we
sort of see from the trailer is at one
point you're like we're gonna kill this
thing which is obviously like as anyone
in a horror movie I'm just like not
like this is the guy that's gonna save
the day because it seems like a dumb
proposition
in the movie but as an actor you know
like the movie lives or dies by that
moment because that is the moment when
it's like we fight back set that up for
us and just know it again this is this
is why you watch the movie for when they
fight back when they fight back with the
crazy thing is here's the thing Clemens
is a doctor he is ill-equipped like you
know he doesn't even like guns so it's
like bruh you gonna do what you're gonna
okay you know and that's the great part
is like you get to watch this guy figure
that out he goes from a scientist a
person who believes in science a doctor
to who doesn't believe in the
Supernatural to a Believer to then a
hunter right like he becomes that any
it's because he has to it's because he's
had to learn to adapt in life and he he
grew up on boats and so he's an underdog
and like you're right like you watch him
in a trailer you like
here you go like you're gonna do what
like we all know how it ends bro you
know but you watch that journey and
that's the thing this movie pulls the
rug out from under you because you know
the ending before you think you know the
ending but you don't know that you know
and so it sets it up in a really cool
way uh and it's just a great uh device
you know um but that's the thing he he
finds that constitution in himself where
everybody on that ship is doubting him
and doubting his presence and doubting
his existence almost
and believing in this other thing he's
like no he's wrestling that back and
taking that yeah he's facing that evil
and I think that's really really cool
you know I mean it is really cool but
I'm not gonna lie to you I was just
thinking of this poor in person but one
person that you have with you who I
think has the appropriate amount of fear
is the character of Anna brought to you
by Iceland because like she really like
gives us this like she gets it and every
one of these stories needs this one
person this is like the Ripley character
in a lot of ways they're like you do not
understand this is a problem
listen women women been saving our hives
you know she's the one she's the woman
on board who is literally telling these
men what is right in front of their
faces and they don't want to see it
including Clemens and so yeah
you know I mean it's it's it's it's just
it's it's his story as old as time but
it's one of those things that that I
think makes her such a she's a great
actress I mean Ashling is literally one
of my favorite actresses I was so glad
we got to rock together on this film
um but you you have this character
literally telling you what what it is
and reminding us the danger and the
horror but that's the thing that's the
thing that you they because here's the
other side of it it's like she's what
she's telling us is like do you really
want do you really expect me to believe
that there's some monster who is
calculating this and rationing come on
like so you know you can understand a
bit of the skepticism
um but it's it's yeah it's it's
interesting to a point but then there's
the point where they all have to like
get on board I did want to add this
really quick though before we get out of
here is the fact that you all are like
literally living in these accents right
and you have the same dialect coach as
the one from Macbeth this is like such a
different British accent because it has
to be period and also of a certain class
but not quite like talk about the
dialect Kate Wilson I actually work with
her at Juilliard as a student broke
college student like back in the day
she's worked with me on Broadway
uh several times on Broadway
um and also on a couple other films but
then we did Macbeth together the
Shakespeare film and when they asked me
to do Demeter I was like we gotta bring
on Kate and so Kate worked with all of
us
on it and you're right it's there is a
there is a it's period but it's also
there's no recordings of of
there's rare recordings from that period
from Sailors let alone a black Cambridge
educated Doctor Who in my backstory also
you know had roots from he grew up on
ships you know the black community of
sailors in Portsmouth or or wherever you
know so it's a very specific thing and
we had to work from a lot of different
materials and phonetics and and pulling
together what this is because I couldn't
just listen to you know the Brits now
like you know it's a different thing
that acts in and we might hear that now
and say oh well that's different from
that so he's not doing it but it's a
very specific calibrated thing and uh
and it was also just a pleasure because
this black American actors we don't also
we don't get the opportunity to do that
that often there and so I was like you
know what I'm gonna run towards it and
see what happens and yeah great job
getting one back for Idris I'm just
kidding I'm kidding I'm kidding that's
just that's just nothing thank you so
much back court I mean I've just been
doing an American accents and got like
since the 90s practically like that you
say Idris
Idris yeah he a legend
he's an accident his American accent
better than mine so you know
great we no longer plot our course
the devil below death
and we all know where he plans to
deliver us
to Hell Mr Clements
Liam I'm going to start with you because
this is obviously a Dracula this is a
horror story but your character and your
performance it's a little bit more
because you also are narrator to this so
it's like a very intense voice acting
performance I think that's so
interesting that your character goes
through those various points because he
really is what brings us into the story
and lets us know that like Trumbull is a
put yes it's a good point to make and
your audience should know that the
reason I'm narrating is because the the
entire movie is based on one chapter in
the book which is the Captain's Log uh
and that's where it and it's very sparse
in the book it's this love where he says
one of our guys is missing there's
something malevolent on this so we it
was in honor of the book that my
narration takes place the character of
of Elliot which we have to kind of build
from the ground up is an interesting
he's a decent man these are merchant
seamen they're blue color guys who
deliver packages and merchandise around
the world
and they're visited by this horrific
Beast who treats the ship like his
refrigerator
um and and that's what's I think that's
what's really interesting these decent
men and there's not a wasted character
on board on this ship ever they're all
kind of good people and I think that's
what what's important you can have
whatever month of the months you want
and as David has said before and I've
said
if you don't have people who care about
you're not going to care about the film
and I think you care about these people
yeah I was going to say we'll check that
character is an interesting one because
I think uh on this vote whenever there's
something afoot there's going to be
people that are instant to believe
people are less likely to believe in
most people somewhere in between but
sort of watching your character sort of
evolve on his thoughts about the
presence was definitely one that was
interesting and probably more
interesting to you is the character
because let's be real this is a it's an
ensemble in a lot of ways
um and the sense of like you want to
have a moment but your character really
does like the moment is watching him
basically come to the realization that
this is really happening because he's
the sort of first mate and if this
didn't happen he was about to become a
Captain with the less Voyage of the
Demeter being that it's an ensemble
piece and being it there's all these you
know different voices and opinions about
how stuff works it's like the real world
you've got people who are very
superstitious you've got people who are
like there's a scientific approach to
this how are we gonna are we gonna
Vanquish this thing that's that's
threatening all of our lives and here
comes this guy Clements this educated
man who looks different from me who in
my opinion doesn't belong on board a
ship who's trying to tell me how to do
things and unfortunately for voycek he's
come to find that there is a way you do
things this is how a boat works this is
how life operates this is who belongs
where
um my captain my hero my mentor is
starting to fall apart people are
starting to go missing the way that I've
myopically focused on denying evidence
in spite of the fact that it's starting
to literally leave puddles of Blood on
the deck of my ship has been detrimental
to the success
of Dracula himself so coming to that
realization and coming to the acceptance
of the fact that there is something
beyond my understanding that I am
powerless over is and was for me as an
actor an incredible thing to tap into
and this might seem like a grand
metaphor but for anyone who's watching
who gets the metaphor for me is a
recovering addict and somebody 21 years
into recovery it's so funny how you
could be so focused on this is the way
this works none of that BS is is true
and that's when you're you're most
vulnerable that's when you're most in
danger and I love that I get to go on
the journey where I recognize that
Clements isn't just my Ally he's
actually the guy who has the answers
that I never realized I needed and I
find a friend in him before we reach the
end of the last Voyage of the Demeter
yeah the interesting thing about both of
you guys in this is that where we start
you and where we end you in this story
is just so different and watching these
characters and that's for every
character in this not just your two
everyone is in a different place but the
one thing that sort of centered is it is
your dedication to the Demeter your pair
of dedication to the ship to its crew to
various degrees so Liam I'll start with
you they really sort of embody the idea
of like there's something here to
protect like they're the people that are
like we have to to stay the course and
it's almost because of their love of
sailing that makes it to where again
it's it's part of the engine as it will
the plot the fact that they're like
we've been through harder time yeah very
much so you have to remember the people
that do difficult jobs like that leave
their families go off military people uh
you know people in all sort of walks of
life
they find a comfort in those people they
work with that they live with 24 hours a
day they have to get on it is their
family it's their second family in some
cases it's their only family and voice
check is is like that
um with Elliot he's come to the end of
that Journey at the beginning of the
movie and it's handing over the Reigns
to this their home to voiceek
which is obviously before we come across
our friend uh who's coming out to uh to
destroy all that so the setup for this
drama is magnificent and when he does
show up this is not the Dracula that
we've seen many many times this is not a
Seducer in a cape you know an attractive
man who's mysterious and somehow
magnetic um what we have as a force of
nature a beast
um a malevolent
a moral animal who's after these
unfortunate decent men and I think that
makes for seriously good drama uh one of
the things I think is also really
interesting is the way that Andre has
done Dracula he brought back his
collaborator Javier who's uh again
embodies the monster on set I he
definitely talked about how it makes it
more real David I have to ask you
because you do get to do a lot of sort
of like the body acting with this
version of Dracula that is not something
where you really have to act too hard I
would imagine it's such a gift it's so
cool I'm a kid who grew up addicted to
monster movies my earliest heroes in
cinema were Lon Chaney who would vanish
into the makeup of his work Bella Lugosi
obviously is a great Dracula but look at
Boris Karloff and how he vanished into
Frankenstein's monster so seeing Javier
who I've admired his work I'm a big fan
already become Dracula and the work that
you're in and the rest of the makeup
effects team did craft this Nusrat to
come vampire bat come demon uh look with
with Andre was so cool and it's dimly
lit we're in the the hold of a ship a
lot of my battling with Dracula's taking
place under the deck or late at night
and so he's moving in the shadows and
the way that guy uses his body and has
such a control over his instrument is oh
man yeah I was scared
I would only I would only imagine all
right real quick before I get out of
here favorite Dracula that you've gotten
to see Lamb David real quick oh with me
it's a bit like the James Bond thing you
know Sean Connery was my James Bond
Christopher Lee was my Dragula until I
came across it's now Javier what about
you David I'm gonna go I love Chris Lee
he's a hero to me but I've got Bella on
my socks today so Bella Lugosi we'll go
back to Bella Christopher Lee's my very
close but Bella Lugosi Liam can have
Chris and I'll take Bella
[Music]
in the night it rings our blood that he
is on this ship
we will never leave it
I heard you describe this as basically
alien on a ship was that sort of like
something that really just intrigued you
about the story to begin with like talk
about your history and how you sort of
started with the project yeah absolutely
I mean that's when I read the script
which I was lucky enough to even read
and then it was definitely the
uh this idea of creating to portray
Dracula in a way you've never seen him
before as this monster on a ship you
know in story terms it's kind of like
alien yeah you're out on a ship there is
nothing around you cannot Escape you
know it's a blueprint in a way for
creating tension and for creating
contained environment to create a you
know horror movie I just wanted to make
the scariest Dracula movie I've seen
that that was my goal yeah and that's so
funny too because you wanted to make the
scariest Dracula movie but then you also
were not really like married to one
version of Dracula as it were we see
like various iterations was that also
something from like the early days of
this script because we really do see a
metamorphosis of even what we call
Dracula in this movie yeah absolutely I
mean in a way he is sophisticated
Aristocrat you know because that's what
he is in in uh in Romania that's what it
is in London but I think we had to focus
on on just a monster aspect of him and
tell this journey of this old fragile
man who has gotten himself into a
journey he wasn't in a way maybe quite
prepared for her and he's in dire
trouble when when he loses his blood
supply Anna and he has to start
attacking the crew to survive yeah and
at some point he does gain the powers he
he does become the Demonic force of
nature that he is and um and then he
ends up you know becoming
the ultimate version of Dracula yeah I
think it's so interesting too because
throughout these um various iterations
you're back with Javier and I I dare to
say this and I know this is like a lot
of comparisons considering that you
produce scary stories tell in the dark
with Guillermo del Toro but I see a
pairing of you and Javier that could be
as similar of his with Doug Jones like
just this idea of like creature
performers following you know these
monster creators throughout films is
that something that sort of intrigues
you as well Javier would be at the top
of my mind any movie that had but it was
not just as a creature performer he's a
great actor I mean he's a really great
actor what do you think that he brings
particularly to these performances that
that really sort of shines out in the
Dracula I mean he has a Nuance about his
body movement and he has like obviously
his look is very is very unique he
thinks like the character he behaves
like the character he really lives the
character on screen when you're working
with him on set and when he's portraying
take by take by take he gives you
sometimes surprise missing choices that
he comes up with on the spot that you
can film for a couple of minutes maybe
and actually do seven eight takes on a
go in a go without breaking the camera
and he would just give you versions and
versions of how Dracula could behave
and it's um because he has all these
things in his mind and in his body and
his knowledge of what a creature can
what he can do with his body is also
totally unique so I think it must be
interesting too for the scene Partners I
mean look Corey ate something like
everyone
um in this production for the most part
has they're very seasoned performers and
so they've definitely seen folks doing
creature performances they've seen heavy
makeup performances did you have any of
them remarked about how different it is
because it is very different when you
have it the way you have it on set here
where like literally he is just the
monster there's not like a character
that you're really interacting with but
it almost makes it like you can really
suspend this to leave if you want to
yeah and I remember when we were
shooting the scene when Woody gets
bitten we didn't want and Woody didn't
want to see Dr didn't want to see Javier
he'd met him many times but he didn't
want to see him in costume until the
camera was rolling so we were literally
keeping him off the set while we start
the camera rolling and Woody doesn't
know what is he's facing and then he
walks in Out of the Shadows on you know
when it's happening on camera to capture
his reaction in a proper way and the
fear he has in his eyes when he sees him
the first time and it's just uh it was a
way to to make it all work yeah and
Woody um plays Toby the young boy and
this one correct and he's like I think
Fox will recognize him from monk Mon and
other kind of stuff but I think it's so
interesting because this film like I'll
just put it you guys are pulling no
punches right is that correct so like
you guys are really I would just say
that that if this is going about making
the scariest Dracula movie you're taking
the scariest sort of like elements from
everything that they've mentioned before
and really sort of going for it was that
also something that you really had to
because I just put it this way this is
not scary stories until the dark this is
not a teen like this is a hard R scary
movie and you guys really lean into that
yeah no I mean I was so happy that
everyone embraced the deaths in the
movie because there are a couple of ones
that I'm sure is going to be talked
about maybe you know at least
um
yeah and uh I think but I think that's
you know we have to portray things in a
way we believe is the best story you
know it's a
I really do think again this is going to
get folks talking about it the thing I
just want to you know make sure that I
say uh before we get out of here is this
idea that you have an horror great
collaborators it's such a collaborative
filmmaking process but the best part is
talking to other horror heads about it
and this again is going to be a movie
that's going to get people talking one
person that you probably talked about
with this one was guaraldo Del Toro who
I know sort of like recommended you for
this project talk a little bit about
like just the filmmaker to filmmaker any
conversations you had with him about
this I mean very little he got so busy
with with night morale around the time I
by the time I got into this but it was
you know he's been a super yes he's been
very supportive and he recommended me
and it was all
uh I wouldn't you know I wouldn't have
been making it without his
recommendations so you know I'm in great
depth to him for sure have you gotten a
chance to let him see it yet no and I'm
looking forward to that actually I hope
you know I'm also scared of it
I did it fair enough actually fair
enough thank you so much Andre